Let us now move from the
abstract to the concrete.
Recall the example that we
discussed earlier where we
have two rolls of a
tetrahedral die.
So there are 16 possible
outcomes
illustrated in this diagram.
To continue, now we need to
specify a probability law,
some kind of probability
assignment.
To keep things simple, we're
going to make the assumption
that the 16 possible outcomes
are all equally likely.
And each outcome has a
probability of 1 over 16.
Given this assumption, we will
now proceed to calculate
certain probabilities.
Let us look first at the
probability that X, which
stands the result of the first
roll, is equal to 1.
The way to calculate this
probability is to identify
what exactly that event is in
our picture of the sample
space, and then calculate.
The event that X is equal to 1
can happen in four different
ways that correspond to these
four particular outcomes.
Each one of these outcomes has
a probability of 1 over 16.
The probability of this event
is the sum of the
probabilities of the outcomes
that it contains.
So it is 4 times 1 over 16,
equal to one fourth.
Let now Z stand for the smaller
of the two numbers
that came up in our two rolls.
So for example, if X is 2 and
Y is equal to 3, then Z is
equal to 2, which is the
smaller of the two.
Let us try to calculate the
probability that the smaller
of the two outcomes
is equal to 4.
Now for the smaller of the two
outcomes to be equal to 4, we
must have that both X and
Y are equal to 4.
So this outcome here is the only
way that this particular
event can happen.
Since there's only one outcome
that makes the event happen,
the probability of this event
is the probability of that
outcome and is equal
to 1 over 16.
For another example, let's
calculate the probability that
the minimum is equal to 2.
What does it mean that the
minimum is equal to 2?
It means that one of the dice
resulted in a 2, and the other
die resulted in a number
that's 2 or larger.
So we could have both
equal to 2.
We could have X equal
to 2, but Y larger.
Or we could have Y equal to
2 and X something larger.
This green event, this green
set, is the set of all
outcomes for which the
minimum of the two
rolls is equal to 2.
There's a total of five
such outcomes.
Each one of them has
probably 1 over 16.
And we have discussed that for
finite sets, the probability
of a finite set is the sum of
the probabilities of the
elements of that set.
So we have five elements
here, each one with
probability 1 over 16.
And this is the answer
to this problem.
This particular example that we
saw here is a special case
of what is called a discrete
uniform law.
In a discrete uniform law,
we have a sample
space which is finite.
And it has n elements.
And we assume that these n
elements are equally likely.
Now since the probability of
omega, the probability of the
entire sample space, is equal to
1, this means that each one
of these elements must have
probability 1 over n.
That's the only way that the
sum of the probabilities of
the different outcomes would be
equal to 1 as required by
the normalization axiom.
Consider now some subset of the
sample space, an event A
that, exactly k elements.
What is the probability
of the set A?
It's the sum of the
probabilities of its elements.
There are k elements.
And each one of them has a
probability of 1 over n.
And this way we can find the
probability of the set A.
So when we have a discrete
uniform probability law, we
can calculate probabilities by
simply counting the number of
elements of omega, which is n,
finding the number n, and
counting the number of elements
of the set A. That's
the reason why counting
will turn out to be
an important skill.
And there will be a whole
lecture devoted to this
particular topic.